[Music]
you are sending us back to work
with a clear mandate to get canada
through this pandemic and to the
brighter days ahead and my friends
that's exactly
what we are ready to do
there are still votes to be counted
but what we've seen tonight is that
millions of canadians have chosen a
progressive plan
some have talked about division
but that's not what i see that's not
what i've seen these past weeks across
the country
i see canadians standing together
together in your determination to end
this pandemic together for real climate
action
for ten dollar a day child care for
homes that are in reach for middle class
families
i hear you when you say that you just
want to get back to the things you love
not worry about this pandemic
or about an election
that you just want to know that your
members of parliament of all stripes
will have your back through this crisis
and beyond
the moment we face
demands real
important change
and you have given this parliament and
this government
clear direction
thank you my friends